all of our programs are focused
on collaborations that we have with the
district not because we have to use
teachers who
are strong and in Spanish and also in
English and also on the students and
that is the most important part is the
students and also the families
is a bird  colorado and in english and also
in spanish so apart from the classes
in english and also part of the classes
in spanish
this is something very interesting not in
bilingual education it is important
because the children need both
languages ​​but if they are not studying in
the  They are going to lose two languages, no,
so that is why it is very important that they
have instruction in mathematics,
science, and whatever in English and
also in Spanish.
It's like 40 percent of the
students themselves, if they speak
Spanish, there's a large population of
people, yes, they speak
Spanish and  So this impressed you
can help these students there are
many students exercises from
all parts of the Greek who speak
Spanish as their first language
and so from time to time when you
enter the class
the teachers will not know what to do no
then this program  Teachers are being prepared
to teach in English and
also in Spanish in reading and
math and science, so it's not
a bad thing if a student and among the
class doesn't speak two languages, it's something to
celebrate and our students are
learning methodologies to celebrate
two cultures.  and two languages
well if when they graduate they are going to be
faced with two languages
then if you enter the path of
any central path for your career
you can use it
so for example if you are a
mate more if you are doing a
math or science project you can  do it
in two languages ​​because this the children have
had classes in two languages ​​so they
have this foundation of two languages
p  ara to extract celebrate
[Music]
hey
ok well I said that this program is
important because our students
are prepared to help families no
it's not just the students in the
class and we use
social justice it's the center of what we
do here no so another  time
we are celebrating families and
also children and what they bring to
class if you are interested in our
programs you can contact us the nsc de
déu